Listen, I'm British-born
and by a Nigerian raised.
There were expectations,
different ways I was supposed to go.
My career options for one,
some of you may already know.
As an African, you get three choices.
Please, repeat after me.
You are going to be a doctor --
Audience: A doctor.
FB: A lawyer.
Audience: A lawyer.
FB: Or a business man.
Audience: Or a businessman.
FB: Now, I did a thing
that brought on quite a bit of stress.
That was me saying, "Mum,
babes, I did my best,
but that's not how I'm going to go.
I'm going to be an actor."
"Why do you want to prostitute
your emotions for money?"
Was my mum's reaction.
Now, in all fairness,
what I was asking for
was this complete abstraction.
But the more I succeeded,
the more my mum could see, right?
Her idea of what was possible
was being reimagined
with me.
I was the lead on the West End.
I was about to be a part, a small part,
a walk-on part in a massive film.
I'm building my career and then boom.
I’m falling apart, and it seems
I am dealing with climate anxiety.
Building my dream and watching the world
literally burn in front of me
and very little being done.
I'm panicking.
Frozen like a mannequin.
Until I see environmental
activism happening,
and I jump in.
But whilst on the protests
and in the meeting rooms,
a question takes over me.
Why don't these people look like me?
Why is it when I think
about climate activism,
I think about white middle-class people?
Is it a white middle-class problem?
A crisis that seems to require more
time, effort, money, work to do
or know anything about
and I'm talking about those
that have the privilege
to think about anything else but survival.
It feels like people of color
experience barriers
towards the forefront
of the climate movement,
and it seems that the reasons lie behind
our underlining principles of survival.
To keep your head down.
Do your work, and don’t get into trouble.
Survive, and dare to thrive.
Protest, yeah, but only
for imminent survival.
See, we've got family
that's been in this country for 40 years
and still feel like new arrivals.
And we have a history
of disappearing in the night.
Shipped off to someplace or just mourned.
No room for the eco fight.
I mean, me Fehinti Balogun,
on this stage right now doing a TED Talk,
I am about four times more likely
to have force used against me
if I'm arrested
than my white counterpart.
I’m about seven times more likely
to be stopped and searched.
And with a new policing bill
and public order bill,
these biases are only set to increase.
Noise restriction on protests.
Criminalization of protesters
without having to convict them of a crime.
Police can stop and search anyone
saying they have reasonable suspicion
and threaten peaceful protest tactics.
The fear is real.
So, you know.
Keep your head down.
Do your work.
And don't get into trouble.
Get yourself a piece of the pie, right?
But that suggests the payoff
will be in a world
similar to the ones
our parents grew up in.
London was hot, boy.
Forty degrees,
one of the hottest summers in history
after one of the hottest
summers in history.
Some people couldn’t go outside.
Plants were either dried up or on fire.
Countries were either
underwater or on fire.
This extreme weather
is only set to increase.
If crops die, well, that makes
food more expensive,
affecting working class communities,
communities of color first.
That world that they grew up in is gone.
But what if, and go with me on this,
what if climate change is just
a symptom of a bigger problem?
And what if it is the same problem
that causes racism and sexism and ableism?
What if all of these things
are just symptoms
of a bigger problem?
Ready?
White supremacist patriarchal capitalism.
(Applause)
It feels scary
because it feels like a concept,
even though our society
is quite literally based on it.
Infinite growth
with finite resources
at whatever the cost.
Those forms of oppression wouldn't exist
if it didn't make someone money.
I mean, in the UK.
slavery plantations in the Caribbean
provided the raw materials
needed for industrial change and growth
in the British Empire, money.
Not to mention the genocides
and the conquests, more money.
The liberation of oil by liberators,
that deliberate the price
of liberation whilst polluting soil.
Get that money.
Shout out to Shell, by the way,
who historically have taken oil
from my country of origin, Nigeria.
Nigeria, who pollutes almost ten
times less than England.
As do so many colonized countries,
and you know what?
It seems to me
that some of the people
who are the most affected
pollute the least.
The ones who have been
historically stolen from.
Climate change is modern colonialism.
So we know, with all of this,
with a colonial mindset,
with a capitalist mindset
that even if we have a magical technology
that clears the air
and makes everything safe,
it would only operate
in certain neighborhoods.
We’re dealing with structure.
A structure that told me
to keep my head down.
A structure and a media
that chose to omit that six percent
of the population, Indigenous people,
protect 80 percent
of the world's biodiversity.
Chose to omit that one of the most
important climate protests in history
was led by a Nigerian,
Ken Saro-Wiwa of the Ogoni people.
Chose to omit the effectiveness
of grassroots movements
and community action.
People like BEN
and Wretched of the Earth
May Garden Projects, to name a few.
Chose to omit the UK's
constant investment in fossil fuels
takes away from any aid it wants to send
to countries like Pakistan
but then reminds me I should recycle more.
If it is that structure that tells me
it is about my own
individual purpose and guilt,
maybe it's worthless,
I feel the power is in the masses.
So I joined groups.
Local and in my job like cooking.
With all my different hobs.
One being Equity for a Green New Deal.
Pension divestment,
putting pressure on heels.
Then I took lessons from Copwatch UK.
Taught me my rights with police
arrests and interventions,
discerning their intentions.
I learned I have to think radically now.
About strategy.
And kindness.
Kindness for myself
and those right behind us.
To be held by them and to hold right back.
Well, that’s community, right
there is strategy in that.
Then what's my capacity?
How much can I give?
Because I got rent, auditions,
I've got to live.
And when I have my capacity,
I think, well, what's my aim?
Where am I helpful?
How do I give weight to my claims?
It's about strategy, right?
So why integrate?
Well, I speak to ignite,
connect and always agitate.
Let's go back.
Because this is important, agitate.
Call out inaction,
point to solution, tell the truth.
Get all that money out of fossil fuels,
pension investments, accounts,
hand over power,
make them want to be radical.
Connect.
There are people in spaces just like this
that need to be connected
to grassroots movements,
who need the attention,
the space, the funding,
and they need you.
Ignite.
Remind everybody watching
that you are not powerless.
That, "Ah man, there's nothing we can do,
just keep going."
is a symptom,
not cure.
That you stand on years
worth of resistance and success,
that you are needed.
That you, just like my mum,
have the power to reimagine
what you think is possible.
So now we speak.
We strategize.
And we think: How does this
action aid the next step?
Thank you.
(Applause and cheers)